I really felt quite distressed not  receiving an invitation you know welcome  here oh dear what an awkward situation  you've read it favorite who's gonna help  you perhaps you pretty mama who's always  there to make it right plus you pretty  baby I've lived come on them for 20  years ago but in their ways discovering  their secret he likes you  terminator you are under breath oh truck  over I can't add you have the right to  remain silent oh I'll be giving us a lot  of thought I want you to be my best make  me know said actually I was talking to  don't listen don't say nothin right now  man like I knew you and I had a  connection but this is crazy let me tell  you something this means so much to me  I'm not gonna let you down let me say so  I'm gonna be the best best man in the  history of all best men I've always  wanted to be a best man you won't give  me that opportunity we came here to golf  and now you gonna give me this blessing  okay I gotta go to the bathroom